without gender the world as we know it
would fall apart without gendered
clothes choosing an outfit becomes
nearly impossible
oh okay so they just pulled out a shirt
they like well watch what happens with
razors this person is using a non pink
razor on their legs it will tear her
skin to rag well she must have some sort
of leathered skin or titanium move along
the wage gap without gender how would we
know which one to pay last watches
anarchy grips these coworkers they were
doing it earlier ah the big one with
gender-neutral bathrooms a sexual frenzy
would unfold what if they hurt each
other fart no don't over there toy it's
the only wanted Oh
masculinity will fall my dog just died
Oh
femininity will rise up all their bodies
are crumbling under the sheer weight of
the couch actually we're buying watch
pandemonium take hold of these peers the
disgust and contempt she has for people
not conforming to gender assumptions you
can't do pastels here try magenta - much
better
thanks Hannah that was the wrong color
for it you it didn't look right he is
more of an autumn standards of hand
beauty hand ERDs handed beauty